einen wunderschönen guten Tag und guten
Appetit danke hallo wie geht es dir gut
danke machen noch kein oder doch wir
fangen jetzt an über
Gumm l mich kurz einmal
runterschlucken aber am Stück bitte geht
ja dann verkabeln wir wir hatten ja
eigentlich verabredet Jan sie und oder
her delayom
sehr
gut ja wie ist die Lage ah die Lage
ist wie soll ich sagen gut aber
extrem ja extrem rastlos die Lage ist
das eigentlich immer bei dir so ja also
ich meine das letzte Mal haben wir uns
getroffen im Sommer glaube ich ja ja da
war sie natürlich auch extrem rastlos
und letztendlich ist es eigentlich so
dass es seitdem eigentlich nicht
wirklich abgen men hat es gibt natürlich
mal Momente
also z.B über übers Weihnachten konnte
ich dann wirklich mal zwei Wochen
wegfahren
aber ansonsten ist es eigentlich auch
wenn wir nicht am Touren sind konkret
dann bin ich einfach jetzt so wie jetzt
die ganze Zeit am Touren und weil ich
dann dann ist das auch mal so hat man so
viele Anfragen verschiedener Art die z.B
auch noch mal auflegen was ich halt
gerne tu oder
so eine Synchronsprecher Rolle zu machen
und dann sagt man ja jetzt geht nicht
bin auf Tour aber dann im im Mai da habe
ich dann frei und dann übersieht man
aber dass man da ja noch ein Live Album
rausbringen und noch Auftritte und alles
hat und das ist halt wirklich so dass
ist eigentlich echt die ganze Zeit ich
immer unterwegs bin weißt du noch wie es
zu Hause aussieht ja ich komme ja auch
immer mal ich komme ja auch immer mal
wieder nach Hause aber das Ding ist halt
so wenn du wenn du wie gesagt was ich in
innerhalb von vier Wochen immer nur
einmal die Woche in Hamburg bis zu Hause
um die um die Koffer irgendwie neu
zuacken
dann oder selbst wenn du sogar mal dann
einen Tag in Hamburg frei hast dass du
das nie so wahrnimmst weil du einfach
nicht gesettled bist also du du ich
finde man braucht erstmal zum Ankommen
weißt man kann nicht einfach einen Tag
da sein nächsten Tag weg sein und sagen
ja ich war schönen Tag in Hamburg weil
du warst eigentlich auch auf Reisen
obwohl du in Hamburg warst weil du bist
in dem Moment einfach im rastlosen Modus
und dieser Modus stellt sich erst wieder
zurück wenn du mal wirklich ein zwei
Wochen am Stück irgendwo m wann hast du
das letzte Mal Möbel gekauft für deine
Wohnung auch so ein Ding wollte ich
jetzt ich habe im Juni habe ich zwei dre
Wochen
frei wo ich dann schön die WM auskosten
werde und
so und dann wollte ich mich endlich mal
um meine Wohnung kümmern ich bin da 2005
eingezogen da habe ich gerade Mercedes
Dance
gemacht 2007 hatte ich sie dann so
ungefähr zu einem Drittel fertig die
letzten dre Jahre dann wurden daraus
zwei Drittel aber ein Drittel ist immer
noch nicht fertig also seit 5 Jahren und
ja so ich bin im im Prinzip der Typ wie
in dieser Hornbach Reklame weißt du der
das war doch irgwann mal der Claim
machen sie es endlich fertig oder
irgendwie
SAS ja und da wollte ich mich jetzt dann
auch drum kümmern im Juni aber das Ding
ist ja man muss ja quasi rechtzeitig
bestellen weil so weißt du dies das
dauert ja mal se Wochen Lieferzeit und
so und dann habe ich irgendwie versucht
auch nur einen Tag zu finden wo ich
quasi das machen kann in Ruhe mir Sachen
aussuchen und bestellen damit ich im
Juni das ganze dann irgendwie aufbauen
einrichten und ausräumen kann ich habe
keinen Tag gefunden das heißt ich kann
im Juni erst losgehen und gucken und
dann kommen die Sachen erst 6 7 Wochen
später und da bin ich dann schon wieder
in Japan oder was weiß ich also es ist
echt Wohnung einrichten gerade wenn man
darauf viel Wert legt so dann ich bin
halt so einer der sagt ne dann mache ich
es erstmal nicht weil ich habe keinen
Bock auf so
halbgares und jetzt zwei Drittel sind
perfekt aber ein Drittel ist ja und vor
allem bei den zweirittel das ist jetzt
auch schon so wie wie bei einer
U-Bahnstrecke weißt du wenn du du
sanierst die ganze Strecke und wenn du
hinten angekommen bist musst du
eigentlich vorne schon wieder anfangen
weiter zu sanieren also ich ich merke
jetzt quasi schon bei den zwei Dritteln
die fertig sind wo es schon wieder
abbröckelt und alles der Putz runterkmt
von den Sachen die halt vor 5 Jahren zum
Einzug gemacht wurden das ist
ja keine Ahnung aber ich bin ja auch
Musiker und kein in ich wollte gerade
sagen kannst du das überhaupt dich dann
so sozusagen jetzt mache ich mal jetzt
schreibe ich kein Stück jetzt arrangiere
ich nichts sondern jetzt mache ich was
anderes oder ist das so wenn du muss ich
zwangsläufig also weil weil abgesehen
davon dass mir das auch wirklich Spaß
macht so so eine Wohnung
einzurichten habe ich ja sowieso keine
Zeit dafür gehabt aber ich habe im im
letzten Jahr seit wir uns getroffen
haben auch n so nichts arrangiert oder
so man ist ja die ganze Zeit in einem
bestimmten Genre seines Arbeitsfeldes
tätig wo es n mal nichts oder sehr sehr
wenig mit kreativen Schaffensprozess zu
tun hat die zwei Jahre davor oder die
anderthalb Jahre davor habe ich jeden
Tag arrangiert und gemacht und getan
aber wenn die Platte dann fertig ist und
rausgeht in die Welt und man selber muss
auch rausgehen in die Welt um sie
bekannt zu machen da ist nicht mehr viel
mit kreativen Schaffen da ist vielleicht
kreatives Leben und kreatives time
Management gefragt
aber du erschaffst da nichts und ich ist
bei mir auch immer so ein Tonus weil ich
laufe durch diesen Tonus jetzt echt
schon 15 Jahre oder so und ich merke
halt jetzt schon wieder irgendwann so
nach einem Jahr wenn man wirklich ein
Jahr nichts erschaffen hat dann kommen
automatisch so komische nicht Zuckung
aber es zuckt so hoch so Anwandlung dass
man wieder sich mehr Sachen aufschreibt
und de mehr Sachen einfallen und dass
man auch langsam wie so Hummeln im Arsch
hat dass man wieder unbedingt eben
wieder schaffen will was zugt dann so
hoch regy HipHop fun im Moment am Anfang
erstmal weil ich auch so lange kein Beat
mehr gemacht habe also einfach Beat im
Sinne von ich setze mich jetzt mal hin
und ma ein Beat so wie wie wir das
früher jeden Tag gemacht haben weil ich
ja auch einfach so viel mit der Band
zusammenarbeite dass ich denen meine
Beats quasi einfach nur vorsumme und die
spielen dann ein aber ich sitze nicht
mehr vom Rechner und programmere selber
und deshalb ist es im Moment eher sind
es textliche Sachen also äh und die
werden nicht gleich zugeordnet ob man
das daraus jetzt ein Rapsong macht oder
ein ein ein ein Funk oder Popsong weil
weil erstmal ist es nur meistens kommt
nur eine Zeile oder ein Thema oder ein
so Fragmente und ob es jetzt ein Rapsong
wird oder ein anderer Song kann ich dir
immer erst sagen wenn ich mehr davon
habe also von dem Text das da kommt
immer wieder ein bisschen mehr so dazu
und
ähm dann hat man so eine Seite im rybook
wo man dann die Sachen
dazuordnet die dazu passen könnten und
vielleicht hat man dann noch einen
Einfall für ein anderes Fragment dann
glättert man ein paar Zeilen weiter
schreibt paar Seiten weiter und schreibt
das dann da dazu und so so füllt es sich
dann langsam und wenn man dann auch noch
irgendwann die Zeit und Muße hat wieder
Musik zu erschaffen dann fügt es sich so
langsam zusammen dann merkt man so okay
die Textidee könnte eigentlich mit der
Songidee mit der musikidee ganz gut
harmonieren oder das dieser Text wäre
doch mal eigentlich ein ganz geiles
rapthema da würde ich mal raptext jetzt
draus machen und so und so läuft das
dann und dann das ist halt eine Phase wo
man dann auch
ähm komplett eintaucht auch wieder nicht
seine Wohnung renoviert und einrichtet
weil man dann sagt nee ich muss ins
Studio ich muss schaffen und wenn man
das dann anderhalb Jahre gemacht hat
dann zuckt es wieder weil dann kommt
wieder der berühmte Tonus in mir zum
Vorschein der mir sagt so du hast jetzt
lange genug geschaffen und in deinem
Studio darum gehockt und der bist genug
Autist gewesen und jetzt musst du so
raus in die Welt und den Leuten diese
Songs präsentieren und das kommt halt
auch immer automatisch und durchzuckt
mich und dann
ja und dann geht das wieder los und das
gibt's jetzt als Platte genau das
Ergebnis dieses genau das stimmt stimmt
stimmt genau das Album das Studioalbum
und das Live Album
ist das noch mal eine neue Arbeit daran
zu gehen all die Stücke aufzuarbeiten um
s auf der Bühne zu bringen was die
andere Arbeit noch mal ist ist diese
Show zu konzipieren also wenn man jetzt
die Platte fertig hat und sich sagt okay
wir gehen jetzt auf Tour wir wollen das
jetzt live spielen dann guckt man
natürlich okay
welche Songs oder Passagen eignen sich
für Live welche eignen sich weniger dann
baut man die irgendwie um die wenn es
nur eine Passage ist baut man die um
wenn es ein ganzer Song ist überlegt man
sich den Song vielleicht ganz anders zu
spielen oder ihn wegzulassen oder man
probiert halt so rum man baut eine
Dramaturgie für die Show auf bei uns
ganz wichtig sind uns immer die madleays
also quasi wo wir dann so ein Z D 4 Club
Hits in eins packen die super auf der
Platte genau
genau genau und
und das ist dann auch Arbeit aber auch
kreatives Schaffen das macht auch
wirklich Spaß und da sitzen wir halt
auch sehr lange dran und auch wenn man
dann quasi auf Tour geht ist es immer
noch so dass man am ersten Tag ist die
Show ganz anders als sie am letzten
Tourtag ist da ist sie komplett anders
da ist die Reihenfolge anders da hat man
Songs rausgeschmissen reingeholt man man
man merkt und lert ja die ganze Zeit mit
jedem Auftritt und deshalb ist es das
ist dann die Arbeit aber eine Live
Platte aufzunehmen ist halt überhaupt
keine Arbeit we wir sind ja sowieso da
wir spielen ja sowieso das Konzert und
das das nimmt man dann einfach gerne mit
weil es für uns kein extra Aufwand ist
und wir das geil finden einfach für uns
selber so ein so ein Dokument zu haben
was wir uns in Regal stellen können und
immer wieder rausholen können wenn wir
in 30 Jahren darüber senieren auch wie
geil waren das damals mit der disconam
wen ja wobei man sagen muss wenn du
sagst nicht aufwendig die Show selber
die klingt unglaublich to ist sie wie
gesagt das ist ja auch diese ganze
Vorbereitung das sind ja auch nicht nur
wir die jetzt die da jetzt im Proberaum
versauern ähm und wirklich auch lange
schuften und ackern und tun sondern
parallel wird ja auf allen Ebenen so
geschuftet und geackert z.B unser
Lichtmann der dann der dann irgendwie
halt dann ein ein Bühnenbild designen
muss und ein neues Lichtkonzept was im
besten Fall noch keiner andere vor uns
hatte präsentieren muss und sich so und
auf all diesen Ebenen sind halt Leute
die mit uns immer dabei waren und mit
uns gewachsen sind und für die das jetzt
auch eine vollkommen neue Welt ist wie
genauso wie es für mich das eine neue
Welt ist dass erstmal bei Wetten das zu
sein ist es für für unseren Lichtmann
das das erste Mal gewesen dass er quasi
dass ihm jemand sagt hier du hast Geld
und Budget zur Verfügung wir gehen in
große hilen mach mal eine lighthow oder
eine Bühnenshow die dafür würdig ist so
und der war auch vollkommen aufgeregt
und dachte Gott schaffe ich das
überhaupt ich komme von ganz wo anders
genauso da wo wir auch auch herkommen
aber ich habe immer gesagt ey wir das
ist doch gerade das geile wir wachsen
alle zusammen wir haben da Bock drauf
und wachsen an unseren Aufgaben und ähm
ja du kannst jetzt auch sagen nö ist mir
zu viel das ist da sehe ich mich nicht
dann wirst du den gleich das gleiche den
gleichen Weg beschreiten wie wie jeder
Künstler der irgendwann an dieser
äh ja an dieser Kreuzung steht und dann
heißt es entweder ich setze alles aufs
Ganze ich will noch weiter hoch hinaus
und ich ich denke ich kann das irgendwie
bedienen oder du denkst nee das mir
alles zu viel ich Gehre um oder gehe den
anderen Weg und dann wird man aber auch
nie über einen gewissen nenn es
Bekanntheitsgrad nenn es was auch immer
hinauskommen dann ist es klar dass man
sich und seine Kunst für immer limitiert
hat was auch völlig okay ist und völlig
cool und ich kann das auch echt krass
verstehen weil ich ja auch weiß was es
bedeutet wenn du eben nicht wenn du eben
sagst du willst noch weiterinaus dann
kommen wir wieder zu der Rastlosigkeit
und all dem
deshalb habe ich da volles Verständnis
für aber ich selber wollte es halt mit
mir und meiner Band einfach mal
ausprobieren und ausloten und kann sagen
es macht auch Spaß okay aber hast du
dann nicht wenn man sowas riesiges macht
nicht auch richtig Schiss ja hat man
also vor allem finanziell es ist halt
wirklich so wenn du so eine Tour planst
es hat ja auch das hat so viele so
vieles ist dann anders also du musst
erstmal wenn du in solche heilen gehst
wo du noch wo wir noch nie waren außer
als Vorband für Christina agera da waren
wir jetzt qu da habe ich den ein Schluss
gefasst okay ich sehe jetzt wir können
mit unserer Band so so ein riesiges Ding
irgendwie füllen selbst wenn wir hier
nur 25 Minuten spielen und überhaupt
keine Bühnenshow haben weil das hat
alles Christina haben wir da irgendwie
gerockt wir müssen da müssen wir hin so
das war so das Ziel so und dann heißt es
aber du musst dann quasi wenn du in
solche heilen gehst auch viel früher in
den Vorverkauf als wir das vorher
gewohnt waren früher war es so ja du
machst eine Platte ist fertig dann und
dann wird die Tour geplant geht ein
Vorverkauf alles gut jetzt musst du aber
quasi schon in den Vorverkauf fast gehen
bevor die Platte überhaupt fertig ist
damit du diese sechs Monate einhältst
und da kriege ich natürlich riesen
Schiss weil ich bin Perfektionist ich
weiß ja gar nicht ob ich das schaffe mit
der Platte ob die dann fertig ist und
dann diese Riesen Hallen ob wir die
überhaupt füllen und dann wirst du das
erstm mit Summen konfrontiert von den du
noch nie im Leben vorher was gehört hast
und da merkst du auf einmal oh was das
für eine krasse Verantwortung ist also
die du quasi nicht nur für dich selber
weil letztendlich stehst du dafür gerade
ne wenn das Geld nicht wieder reinkommt
aber auch für diese was ist dann auch
wenn du dann merkst okay wir haben die
lighthow und Bühnenshow da brauchen wir
noch mal fünf Leute allein nur für das
Bühnenbild und die Lichter die einfach
so mitkommen die früher nicht dabei
waren und für den Ton eigene Anlage noch
mal drei vier Leute dabei und da merkst
du auf einmal was das für ein riesiger
Rattenschwanz ist und da geht dir dann
echt irwann der Arsch auf Grundeis wenn
du bemerkst scheiße da sind jetzt 50
Leute die arbeiten nur wegen dir da
diesen Tag wenn du jetzt irgendwie
Grippe hast oder wenn Blabla irgendwas
ist so dann Puff so und das sind dann
echt Momente wo man so Schiss hat aber
wenn das dann eben wenn man das Glück
hat dass das alles irgendwie hinhaut und
dass es geil wird dann ist dieser Moment
wo man dann vor diesen 10.000 Menschen
steht und das und man hat es geschafft
dieses seelenlose hässliche Beton
Mehrzweckhallen Ding mit Liebe zu füllen
und mit mit dem was man womit man
normalerweise auch irgendwelche kleinen
Tausender Clubs gefüllt hat und das
gleiche Gefühl kommt rüber und die Leute
sind euphorisiert und alles ist so
ekstatisch dann ist es die schönste
das schönste Geschenk und dann ist alles
wieder gut das ist so ein bisschen wie
junge Eltern die immer erzählen der
kleine nervt mich so aber wenn er mich
angrinzt dann ist alles wieder gut so
ist das dann dann ist es einfach dann
war es das wert so dann weil das sind
Gefühle die kannst du in einem 500ter
oder Tausender Club nie erreichen wirst
du auch nie das ist das kann man nicht
beschreiben wenn 12000 Menschen auf eine
Sache geeicht sind und alle das gleiche
feiern und und ein riesiges Herz haben
und dass dass sie das glücklich macht
genauso wie die Band die da auf der
Bühne steht dann ist es was was da was
halt entsteht was nur bei ja was nur bei
10 000 Menschen entstehen kann das ist
einfach unbeschreiblich schön macht
einem das auch nicht Angst dass man
plötzlich so eine Masse ein so ne das
das habe ich ja alles hinter mir weil m
genau diese ganze Skepsis die ist auch
gut und gesund diese Angst ist auch
wichtig
ähm das habe ich alles schon Gott sei
Dank eben in sehr jungen Jahren mit den
Beginnern einfach durchgemacht und
damals haben wir auch echt zu knabbern
dran gehabt also da hatten wir nicht nur
Angst sondern da ist es bei uns auch
wirklich dann in Ablehnung umgeschlagen
wir haben auch wirklich damals waren das
auch einfach noch ganz stumpf damals
waren die Kids auch so stumpf heute 10
Jahre später die zöfjährigen sind so
viel cooler reflektierter offener ich
glaube da haben wir auch vor demem Jahr
bei dem letzten Interview drüber
gesprochen oder dass D dass sich die
Generation das ist so sich so verändert
hat du merkst einfach die sind alle mit
deutschsprachiger guter Popmusik
aufgewachsen so und das macht aus denen
ganz andere Menschen ganz ich kann mich
mit jedem da über
jedem zfjährigen in meiner Show kann ich
mich heute über nach der Show 10 Stunden
meinetwen unterhalten über über Essen
über Filme über Kultur über Musik über
Politik über was auch immer das war vor
10 Jahren nicht möglich wir haben die
Krätze gekriegt was da für Leute in den
ersten Reihen standen damals das waren
Leute die wussten nicht mal was HipHop
ist die waren da wegen diesen Liebeslied
Typen waren gestern bei Scooter sind
morgen zu Blümchen gegangen weißt du mit
sowas sind die erzogen worden und heute
ist es einfach anders und damals hatten
wir dann eben diese Angst und wie gesagt
auch diese Ablehnung und haben uns haben
ich habe ja auch Songs gemacht genau
daraus resultierend ich möchte nicht
dass ihr meine Lieder singt weil ich
weil damals einfach die faustreel war ey
sobald mehr als 5000 Leuten zu irgendwas
kommen ist da ein großer Prozentteil
Arschlöcher und unsimpmparten dabei weil
das nur mal die Masse mit sich bringt
heute und jetzt weiß ich nein das ist
nicht so ich hatte in Hamburg in der
coloraline Arena 12000 Leute und das
waren die sympathischsten Menschen der
Welt ich würde mit all denen essen gehen
so
m deshalb ja da hat sich vieles
verändert und und deshalb habe ich da
jetzt auch keine Angst mehr das haben
wir alles schon durchgemacht uns da
emanzipiert die Leute die wirklich
wirkliche Spacken waren haben wir alle
verschreckt und haben sie beleidigt die
kommen nie wieder und das ist auch
völlig okay so und das werde ich auch
weiter so tun aber in den letzten 10
Jahren hat sich das dann irgendwie
stetig gebessert und ich habe jetzt ein
so tolles Publikum auf dass ich so stolz
bin
ich habe das beste Publikum der Welt
super das heißt man muss auch Publikum
beschimpfen wenn also es ist die letzte
die letzte Instanz auf jeden Fall wenn
nichts mehr geht dann muss das auch mal
sein so also genauso
wie ja es gibt einfach Situationen da
ist das so so wenn z.B also auch so ganz
unlustige Sachen wie wenn wenn Gewalt
ausbricht oder so du musst aufhören dann
mit dem Set und du musst mit den Leuten
reden das ist einfach wichtig und so da
ist dann auch nicht mehr Spaß und G und
HA sondern da kann halt wirklich
schlimme Dinge passieren so Massenpanik
und so keiner hatte die Absicht auf
einmal passiert und jemand ist tot so
wie bei den Toten Hosen und das möchte
ich bloß niemals erleben sowas und
letztendlich gehört das genauso dazu
dass man eben sein Publikum anschreit
und sagt ey Leute das geht nicht also
natürlich es da darf es niemals
irgendwie Regel sein dass irgendjemanden
einfach gleich sein Publikum anschreib
nur weil ihm irgendwas da nicht gefällt
so war das ja bei uns bei den Beginnern
auch nicht bei uns war das einfach so
wir kamen da raus haben gesehen wollten
irgendwie anfangen zu rappen und die
ersten drei Reihen haben einfach nur
gekreischt weil das einfach so kleine
debile neunjährige bis 13jährige Mädchen
waren die nicht wussten
was sie da wollen oder tun und einfach
nur so komplett euphorisiert waren dass
da zwei Typen waren die sie aus dem
Fernsehen kennen und dann schreien wir
halt sie an und sagen ey das ist nicht
das weshalb wir hier sind und das ist
nicht das weshalb wir wollen dass Ihr
hier seid das hat mit all dem nichts zu
tun und dann so auf die es ist eher so
ein pädagogisches schreien anschrei
therapeutisches anschreien also das ist
wichtig so das ist äh nicht einfach
so gut dann wünsche ich dir noch viele
ähm tolle konzerttouren mit so einem
Publikum mit dem besten Publikum der
Welt dass du dir offensichtlich hart
erarbeitet
hast das
stimmt